We'd like to consider
torques on a body.
Let's draw an arbitrary body,
and let's consider a point s,
that we're about to
calculate the torque.
Now, we know that
forces on the body
can be both internal
and external.
And we'd like to show that
all internal torques will
cancel in pairs.
The way we'll do that is,
suppose we pick an object.
We'll label it with mass
mi, and another object,
we'll label that with mass mj.
These are small mass
elements in the body.
And we'd like to know something
about the internal forces.
Now, let's make the assumption--
and this is the key property--
that the force due to
this interaction between j
and the i-th particle
pointing that way-- and here's
the Newton's third law pair--
that these forces lie--
are directed along the line
connecting the two bodies.
With this assumption,
we'll now show
that the torque due to these
two internal forces, [INAUDIBLE]
Newton's third law
pairs will cancel.
So let's calculate that out.
So we draw our vector from
rsi, and our other vector rsj.
And now we're in position
to add these two torques.
So we have the torque
on s due to this pair is
equal to the sum of
rsi cross fji plus
rs-- that's an r-- make
sure we get that right.
We have rsj cross fij.
Now, the third law pair says
fji is equal to minus fiji.
And so, if we substitute-- let's
put the minus sign over here--
we get rsi minus rsj cross fji.
Now, let's look at this
vector in particular.
We can draw it again over
here, just to see it.
Here s.
Here is rsi.
Here is the vector
rs, that's rsj.
And we want to now consider
the vector rsi minus rsj.
Notice that this
vector is directed
along the lines connecting the
i-th and the j-th particle.
And we've made an
assumption that fji is also
along that line.
So these two vectors,
in this particular case,
are either parallel
or anti-parallel.
And hence, the torque due
to the sum of these internal
forces cancel in pairs.
And this means we
only need to address
the torque due to
external forces that
are acting on individual
elements in a body.